tiembla al plano geopolítico el
canciller ruso se reunió en la ciudad
turca de antalya con la vicepresidenta
de venezuela del xiv rodríguez y aunque
no trascendieron detalles del encuentro
éste se da después de que una delegación
estadounidense viajará a caracas en
busca de acuerdos energéticos con el
país que ha sancionado por años el
encuentro de bercy rodríguez con lávrov
va un poco en la línea de poder
informarle de cuál fue la intención de
lo que se habló allí en en miraflores
además de eso seguramente de avalar y
darlo a espaldarazo a rusia y por
supuesto recordar que en rusia hay
capitales de venezuela tanto las
instituciones como por ejemplo pedevesa
como también de particulares vinculados
al gobierno de nicolás maduro entretanto
el vecino de venezuela colombia fue
designado por el presidente de estados
unidos como el mayor aliado no miembro
de la otan un estatus especial que
contra de privilegios económicos y
militares que tan sólo ostentan 17
países en el mundo bueno eso es un
espaldarazo que le da al gobierno
colombia
y una forma de tratar de dar un mensaje
a venezuela de que está en la zona de
que eeuu está descuidando su patio
trasero y que tiene un aliado muy
importante como lo es colombia pero
bueno eso eso más allá de debe cambiar
un poco la la tónica y la intención del
acercamiento de washington a venezuela
no lo cambia sin embargo la acción de
eeuu podría ser una movida que impulse a
colombia a reconocer el gobierno de
nicolás maduro con quien ha tenido
diferencias durante años